a Quinnipiac poll has just found that
61% of people want to avoid discussing
politics at the Thanksgiving table that
is not a surprising number the
surprising the horrifying number is that
apparently 29% of people want to discuss
politics at the Thanksgiving table and
do you think that 29% is a really
informed group of people no you know
that that 29% is the least formed group
of people in the entire country you know
and I know that that 29% should
certainly not be allowed to vote and
probably should not be permitted in
public unsupervised you know and I know
that that 29% comprises your silly
haired niece and your androgynous cousin
and they're going to bring up politics
tomorrow whether you want it or not so
let's all load up on a little bit more
rhetorical ammo before we settle down to
the Thanksgiving giving table I'm
Michael nlls this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show this
episode is brought to you by good
ranchers claim your year of free meat 15
bucks off and free shipping with my code
nolles kwes at good Ranch .c that is
goodranchers.com promo code Nolls KW
today also quick reminder this is the
best deal of the year right now you can
get 50% off dailywire plus annual
memberships dailywire.com subscribe
right now to join speaking of politics
at the dinner table don't worry I'll get
to how sex toys can cause diabetes later
first I want to open up with politics at
the dinner table Joe Biden celebrated
his 81st birthday and the White House
inexplicably released a picture of him
sitting at a table not even a
particularly Grand table sitting at a
table that looks like truly it could be
in a nursing home with a weird angle and
then this flame like the very Gates of
Hell were opened up and just a massive
flame coming off this cake Joe Biden
gripping the sides of the table for dear
life smiling over the cake alone in a
room every single thing about this photo
is bad whoever runs White House
communications the
photographer this is obviously not
doesn't look like an official White
House photographer it looks like someone
snapped it on a cell phone all these
people should be fired the picture is
the meme of the dog sitting in the
burning house saying this is fine it's
the it is so eminently memeable it's
actually a pre-existing meme that that
one posts when things are falling around
all about them which is what's going on
in Joe Biden's presidency the reason I
bring it up is not merely to dunk on Joe
Biden or to get some White House
staffers fired the reason I bring it up
is because this is a perfect example of
people being too clever by half this is
a perfect example of political
operatives trying to solve a problem and
in so doing making the problem worse
here's the problem it's Joe Biden's 81st
birthday and most people think he's too
old to be president so what they
ordinarily would have done usually once
you're above the age of
I don't know five instead of putting
individual candles for every year of
your life people just put two candles in
the shape of numbers so you'd have an
eight and a one but that would be so
clear that Joe Biden's 81 they didn't
want to do that so they said okay how
can we get around this without looking
like we're trying to avoid the issue but
still being kind of fun and I know what
we'll do we'll put 81 candles on the
cake yeah that's the ticket and then
people won't count all the candles and
then we're going to light them all on
fire and there's going to be a bonfire
on the White House table because that's
a lot of candles because Joe Biden's
super old so while trying to avoid
confronting the issue they inadvertently
make the problem worse which is
something that our federal government
does all the time particularly under the
leadership of the liberal establishment
I have a second point on this meme that
I I haven't seen anyone bring up other
than other than yours
truly perhaps because the left sometimes
calls me a a Putin stooge or pro- Russia
or whatever well okay here I guess
here's a point that I got a hand to
Russia and to Putin which is I don't
generally say you got to hand it to
Russia and to Putin but I hear you do
because I seem to recall months ago this
was back in April there was a picture of
Vladimir Putin sitting at a table he was
having a meeting with some other
political person and he was just holding
on to the table he had his hand on the
table just sitting there like I I'm
doing that right now didn't seem unusual
in any way to me and for weeks the
Western media propaganda what it is ran
headlines about how Vladimir Putin
putting his hand on the table was
evidence that he was on the brink of
death that he had cancer and Alzheimer's
and Dementia and Oso schlauer disease
and restless leg syndrome and IBS and I
don't know what any any number of
ailments we could we could tell this
because the Tea Leaf readers in the
western propaganda Outlets could see
exactly the tension that Putin had on
the table all right so we heard about
that for weeks and Putin's still alive
then you get to this picture with Biden
the man is gripping both sides of it I
don't see any of those headlines rightly
so I don't think that either of those
things are evidence that that either man
is on the brink of death but it shows
you what the fake news
is this is something I think Drew may
have been the first one at this outfit
to make this point since Drew was around
when journalism was invented the the
point is that the fake news is not fake
because they get some story wrong the
fake news is fake
because they view every story through a
predetermined ideological lens that is
divorced from reality it's either at
least indifferent to reality and very
often is outright hostile to reality
that's why it's fake it's fake because
you could show the liberal media two
identical pictures of Putin and Biden
the only thing that could be different
on the pictures is the subtle facial
differences between the two men and they
would read the one and they'd say see
this this Putin he's on the how old is
Vladimir Putin he's like 70 or something
Joe Biden's got over 10 years on the guy
I think
and they would say Putin he's on the
brink of death he's fading this is we
need regime change he's going to lead to
nuclear war and then Joe Biden who
Ascent to the presidency actually has
seemed to augur uh nuclear war to Herald
the coming of the Apocalypse uh that guy
they would say he's totally fine happy
birthday Move Along move along now
speaking of Foreign Affairs Israel and
Hamas have tentatively agreed to a
ceasefire and hardliners in Israel don't
like it and I don't know maybe I think
probably most of the pro Palestine
people like it in as much as they want
any kind of ceasefire but what's the
American perspective here because the
American perspective is not identical to
the Israeli perspective even though
Israel is an official Ally of the United
States and the American perspective is
certainly not identical to the Hamas or
the Palestine Liberation view so what's
the American perspective I think it's
good I think it's I think it's a win-win
all around Hamas has agreed to free 50
women and children don't forget Hamas
has 239 hostages in Gaza that's a lot of
people they've agreed to free a little
under a fifth of them this is going to
be over a 4-day
period it would ex Israel has now said
that it will extend the
ceasefire by an additional day for every
10 hostages released so Hamas has bought
itself a little bit more time if they do
10 every day they're going to have you
know another 15 to 20
days we're not really clear as to how
many hostages have already died in Gaza
Hamas will release 50 Israel will
release
150 so it's a three to1 trade still
probably worth it if you're the Israeli
government uh it's not exactly clear
when this goes into effect it's not
exactly clear what happens afterward I
think this is great it's great because
Israel cannot agree to just an outright
ceasing of the war because Hamas poses
an existential security threat by
governing in Gaza so if they say okay
the war's over it's all good and then
Hamas rebuilds we're just going to be
right back in this place five minutes
from now likewise though I'm not with
the hardliners who say that we've got to
just glass Gaza and who cares about all
of the civilians and who cares that half
the population of Gaza is children you
know we got to just we got to do what's
got to be done I don't think that's true
either and I don't I don't think that
satisfies the criteria of just war and
furthermore I think
the perspective that I'm most interested
in here is what the American interest is
and as I've said from the beginning I
think the American interest is to
contain the war so it doesn't expand
Iran has expressed some hope that the
war would not expand okay and looks like
Netanyahu is playing ball
too so if Netanyahu can mortally injure
Hamas
while getting the hostages back
while reducing to some degree the
civilian casualties that seems like a
win-win win this seems like actual
diplomacy for much of my life diplomacy
has gotten a bad rap because it it just
seemed like the the term that liberals
used because they were afraid to
actually fight our
enemies but diplomacy is a very good
thing and it is preferable to out
outright war and one of the big shifts I
think in the right-wing on
diplomacy was Trump because Trump's
foreign policy was unpredictable his
critics would say that it was incoherent
I don't think it was incoherent I think
it was really good Victor Davis Hansen
makes a good good case that Trump had
basically the best foreign policy in our
lifetime that you didn't know what he
was going to do he talked like a dove
and then he dropped the Moab and then he
would refuse to respond to certain
aggression of our enemies and then he'd
kill the top Iranian General and then he
would meet with Kim Jong-un and then
he'd call him short and fat and say he's
going to blow him up with a nuclear
weapon but then he wouldn't blow him up
with a nuclear weapon and you just
didn't know what to do and that oddly
enough was diplomacy and it was very
effective diplomacy and we had relative
Peace So if as far as I'm concerned if
we can fix up the election system if we
can copy you know Argentina or something
and try to conduct elections here in the
supposedly greatest democracy in the
world and we can get a conservative
elected then my main foreign policy aim
for the next year is just to not only
contain the war in the Middle East or
contain the war in Ukraine it's to
contain the errors that Joe Biden is
able to make if we can just minimize the
amount of of screw up that can occur
under his watch and we should never
underestimate that per Barack Obama if
if we could just minimize his ability to
throw the world into World War III that
would be very much in our best interests
now what's in your best interest at the
dinner table good ranchers right now go
to good Ranchers .c use promo code nles
there's a lot at stake this November so
don't be a chicken and shop at the
grocery store per usual head on over to
good ranchers where they've got great
meat meat that is even better than my
meat puns don't miss their Black Friday
yourway sale now live this November get
your favorite meat free for a year that
is one year of free steak salmon chicken
or bacon when you subscribe to any box
right now better yet when you subscribe
on goodranchers.com
you not only get a free gift of meat
worth up to 480 bucks you also get $15
off with code nolles the only deal your
grocery store offers is on expiring
Foods so ditch that meat aisle subscribe
at goodranchers.com it's the best meat
out there the prices are unbelievably
low and then you get incredible freebies
on top of that I don't know how their
finances work but it's just amazing they
these guys are the best in the business
claim your year of free meat 15 bucks
off in free shipping with code nolles
canw at goodranchers.com good ranchers
is the number number one place to get
all American beef pork chicken and
seafood seafood you ever do that when
you were a kid you like seafood B well
you can do that with good Ranchers go
use promo code nesg goodranchers.com
good ranchers American meet delivered
the issue of Israel Palestine is
splitting the Liberals there's a house
Democrat who is just quitting the
progressive caucus because the squad and
the young members of the progressive
caucus are very anti-israel very Pro
Palestine and she's very pro Israel this
is Lois Frankl
I know that there are a lot of
right-wingers out there who don't have
strong feelings on the Israel Palestine
conflict it's it's not my top priority I
feel bad for the innocent people being
killed I I don't like that it's a flasho
that can be stabilize the world but it's
it's not my top
issue some for some people they care
very passionately about it for me it's
not the top
issue it is however I think e everyone
has to agree it is
an excellent wedge issue with the left
the American people still broadly
overwhelmingly agree that they support
the state of Israel regardless of what
you're seeing online or some of the
super avantgard online communities
support for the state of Israel is still
the overwhelmingly popular opinion in
the United States on the left it's much
more split because the radical left
which is increasingly represented in
Congress despises the state of Israel
because they view the state of Israel as
a colonial settler white European
onclave in what ought to be the Muslim
Arab Middle East and they hate the state
of Israel with a burning fiery passion
and you also have Democrats who
vigorously strongly support the state of
Israel so if you're a conservative what
do you do
you exploit that wedge
that's just smart politics I don't think
there's anything immoral about that I
don't think there's anything unjust
about that I think we want to weaken our
opponents here in the United States this
is a great issue on which to do it just
as we want on the domestic social issues
to split the feminists from the pro LGBT
activists and we can do that over the
which is a wedge there so too we should
split the Democrats in Congress the
progressive caucus on this issue of
Israel Palestine even if you don't care
about it all which I know a great many
people don't care about this issue it it
will still even if you don't think one
bit about the Holy Land it will still
benefit you domestically so one good
reason to uh like the Iran Iraq war in
the Progressive caucus you kind of just
want both sides of the Democrats to lose
speaking of this issue splitting the
libs it's splitting them outside of
government too Susan sandon big lib
Hollywood actress was just dropped by
UTA her talent agency for her Pro
Palestine rant she was going on and on
she said Jews are finally feeling what
it's like to be Muslim in the United
States which is a kind of an interesting
rewriting of history that now apparently
Muslims are the ones who have always
felt uh like The Outsider who have
always felt uh like they're not totally
welcome in society yeah but I I don't
know that that's a totally accurate
representation the libs still they
invert reality quite a lot and so what
Susan sandon went on to say was you
don't have to be Palestinian to care
about what's happening in Gaza I stand
with Palestine no one is free until
everyone is free that's not true by the
way that doesn't that's a completely
meaningless statement I have no idea
what that means you could say there's no
justice for anyone until there's Justice
for everyone I think that might be true
because Justice is giving to people what
they deserve but freedom
is not
that an individual can be perfectly free
even in a
tyrannical slavish
Society freedom is not contingent upon
other people freedom is the Perfection
of the will which is contingent on the
Perfection of the intellect you can be
free even sitting in a jail
cell so I I I I don't know what she's
talking about but she says a lot of
crazy things anyway as a result of this
she was dropped from her talent agency
which is not it's actually not the best
look if if you're concerned about Rising
anti-Semitism in the United States it's
not the best look for the Hollywood
talent agencies to say hold on you
oppose the state of Israel you'll never
work in this town again how dare you
there's there's Rising anti-Semitism so
that's not a great look I but broadly
speaking I think Susan sandon Still is
the one who looks bad in this situation
the thing that really gets me about this
whole thing is the kefia if you if
you're just listening to the show right
now you probably can't see it Susan
sandon this this white Hollywood liberal
is wearing a Palestinian cfia she's
wearing the same thing that Hamas would
be wearing and you think okay guys I've
said this from the beginning getting
back to my point on you know even if you
don't really care about this war in the
Middle East you know it's not you don't
want to be on the side with Hamas
generally right generally I think that's
a safe bet you don't act when Osama Bin
Laden's letter to America was going
viral you don't actually have to hand it
to Osama Bin Laden ever under any
circumstances surandon wearing the cfia
what does she think would happen if she
moved to Gaza with all of her liberal
nonsense do you think they would welcome
her with open arms for a brief period
they probably would for the propaganda
but I don't think she would fit in very
well with Hamas or Hezbollah or
Palestinian Islamic Jihad it's just so
Preposterous and obviously she hasn't
thought one one iota about it this this
is this is my kind of issue the kind of
issue that can get a latte sipping
Hollywood liberal to use the old
caricature to wear the the wartime Garb
of
jihadis that is that is an issue that
has driven a people mad now speaking of
picking
sides Bob Vander Platz who's the
president and CEO of the family leader
which is an Evangelical group he just
announced that he is endorsing Ronda
santz for president I'm thrilled to
throw my personal endorsement and
support uh behind Governor Ronda Santos
of Florida we need to find somebody who
can win in 2024 and what we saw in 2022
the supposedly Red Wave really only
happened in Florida and in Iowa governor
de santis took a reliable toss-up state
in Florida and made it complete red one
by 20 points one in demographics that we
haven't won in but he's also done that
by being a bold and courageous leader so
right away it was kind of his
endorsement to lose but as you know
Brett in Iowa uh they go to church with
us they're in our homes they come to our
offices the Leadership Summit but at
last Friday's Thanksgiving Family Forum
he closed the sale with me he was very
clear about we need a president who can
serve two terms not one term we don't
need a president that's going to be a
lame duck on day one you need a
president that's going to surround
themselves with the best and brightest
people versus having a hard time
attracting them again and someone is's
actually going to do what they say
they're going to do and I just think
he's got the spine to do it and I think
he's got the experience to win for
us that's a big endorsement big Iowa
endorsement this follows a big
endorsement from Kim Reynolds who's the
governor of Iowa so what does it all
mean I'll give you my answer in one word
in just one second first though we turn
to to creatures that are not able to
articulate any words at all that would
be your dog and even so you need to feed
your dog Ruff greens right now go to Ru
greens.com the holidays are here while
you're out shopping for your kids your
family your friends don't forget to shop
for your pets too give your dog the gift
of a healthier and happier life with
rough greens naturopathic doctor Dennis
black the founder of Ruff greens is
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America dog food might as well be
considered dead food if you ask me
because it contains very little
nutrition you think about it nutrition
is not brown it's green let rough greens
bring your dog's food back to life Ru
greens is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't need to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
your food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it's supports healthy joints improves
bad breath boosts energy levels and so
much more right now get your free jump
start trial bag so your dog can try it a
free jump start trial bag delivered
straight to your door in just a few
business days go to Ruff greens.com or
call 844 ruff1 123 that's Ru FFG
greens.com m c h A- l or call 844 Ruff
123 today the best deals of the year are
here and yes it includes 50% off new
annual daily War plusus memberships you
will get adree uncensored exclusive
content from all your favorite dailywire
hosts along with groundbreaking
entertainment and documentaries that are
reshaping our cultural landscape but
there are so many more deals Happening
Now inside the first ever dailywire
Black Friday shopping guide find 25% off
the perfect stocking stuffer Jeremy's
chocolate not only are the famous he him
and she her chocolate bars back in stock
we are introducing Christmas themed
chocolate bars with peppermint and dark
chocolate very exciting all 25% off
right now shop all of the Black Friday
deals now inside the daily wire gift
guide that is dailywire.com sblack
Friday the desandis campaign is all in
on Iowa they've already signaled that
they pulled their staff out of other
states they moved them to Iowa Iowa
first in the nation caucus big deal they
want to regain any momentum in the race
in
Iowa and Dan santis has done a good job
on the endorsement front he just got the
endorsement of a major Evangelical
leader in Iowa and he got the
endorsement of the governor of Iowa who
by all accounts is a fairly popular
governor and yet and yet Trump is still
up and he's not up 10 or 20 points he's
up 40
points
so what does that
mean it means that the endorsements
don't seem to be mattering as much this
cycle as they have perhaps in past
Cycles it means that people's minds seem
to be relatively made up it seems that
the people are less persuadable
than the elites within the Republican
Party the elites The Operators the
office holders the political players
they seem to be able to go from side to
side they sit on the fence sometimes
then only at the last minute do they
endorse a candidate but the people seem
to have their minds relatively made up
Vander Platz says look the candidates
here they're not they're not distant
they come to church with us they sit
down in our Civic associations they come
into our living rooms that's
true that's always been true but why
aren't the polls moving we could find
out the the caucuses are in January we
could find out that all the polls were
totally wrong but I don't think that all
the polls are totally wrong one or two
polls maybe I don't think that all the
polls weighted properly by Real Clear
Politics for now what 16 17 18 months I
don't think they've all been totally
wrong by 40
points it tells tells me that this race
is much much less Dynamic than previous
races because you've got a guy who's
running effectively as an incumbent
first guy in over a hundred years who's
running for his non-consecutive second
term as president and even if it works I
I don't I'm not trying to reain on the
parade of the dis santis campaign here
but even if it works the last time Iowa
predicted the Republican nominee was
2000 with George W bush and then
obviously 2004 he he runs for
reelection but 08 they picked hucke 12
they picked Santorum 16 they picked Cruz
so if you're a DeSantis campaign
strategist why are you putting all your
eggs on Iowa even if you could win Iowa
there's no evidence that helps you get
the nomination there's a lot of evidence
it
doesn't unless this is just a Hail Mary
unless dandis is saying well I can't win
New Hampshire I can't win South
Carolina I can't win Nevada maybe they
pulled out it I'm not sure they pulled
out of Nevada I mean I I think that
Trump is basically going to win it all
but even so why pull campaign staff out
of Nevada to go to Iowa unless you want
to be able to say well we got one state
and I don't know and then make a play
for some future position it's looking
like there is a consensus being formed
here it's looking like after a long
primary with no changes
whatsoever broadly speaking people are
beginning to settle in even if some big
endorsements are going on the other side
now speaking of rivalries this is a
story I meant to get to couple days ago
big story gl's finally making the
national
news an ugly Feud writes The Wall Street
Journal is rocking the blue-blooded
Mayflower
Society looming over
Thanksgiving the organization battling
with a pilgrim descendant quote I'm
pissed I was having dinner with my
friend on Sunday night when and this
Wall Street Journal headline popped up
and he turns to me goes you're not going
to believe this he said there's a he
goes have you heard there's a big feud
in the Mayflower Society Mayflower
Society is like 130 years old or so I
think it's 126 years
old in the entire 126 year history of
the Mayflower Society I don't know that
it has ever made a national headline and
now two weeks after the launch of
Mayflower cigars
mostly sold out though maybe you can
check the website Mayflower cigars.com I
think there's still there might be a
handful of packs that have trickled in
for pre-order 21 plus some exclusion
Supply you know the drill two weeks
after the launch of Mayflower cigars the
Mayflower
society makes National
headlines all nature is but art unknown
to thee all chance Direction which thou
canst not see I love this story I mean I
think it's ridiculous the story is
basically that one of the members of the
MF flower Society is just
totally obsessive about legal documents
and he read the main flower Society
Charter which is quite old and he read
Massachusetts state law and he said that
there is a little bit of a conflict here
between the charter and the
Massachusetts state law and the other
members of the main flower Society very
rightly said yeah okay Bob like sit down
who cares and this guy what's his name
Charlie Morgan is suing this has been a
protracted legal battle the society
finally kicked him out cuz they said he
was so annoying and he said absolutely
not I demand to be reinstated in the
Mayflower society and you need to change
your Charter because we're open to
massive legal liability which I don't
think I think the Massachusetts
prosecutors have other subjects on their
mind beyond the bylaws of the main
flower Society but I love the I love the
whole story and I love the MF flower
Society I think I might be the youngest
member of the MF flower Society in the
entire country there are a lot of people
who have Mayflower ancestors but not a
lot of people have gone through the
process of tracing them back and
providing the documentation my
grandfather was really into genealogy so
he did it for our family I think there
are 31,000 members worldwide of this
group and I love that it's in the news
and it's not just because I love the
story of the Mayflower and I love the
pilgrims and I love America it's really
not just because of that I
love the very notion of a genealogical
Society I love when people care about
their family and their family history
and their family's role in history
period I like that I think that's deeply
conservative and I think we live in an
age where we we ignore the past broadly
we we neglect our families we move away
from our families we don't care what our
families have to say we don't feel
obligation to our families and we if we
think about the past at all we think
about it
negatively we we condemn our ancestors
and our forebears and we think that
we're the most brilliant people in the
world because we've got an iPhone and we
can Google things that a generation ago
5-year-olds would have known and we
think we're really smart because of
that I love the idea of a genealogical
society because we live in a very
abstract age where we think that we're
just atoms floating in The Ether where
we think that we're just born into a
state of nature without any ties or
obligations where we think that we're
all just totally undifferentiated that a
people and another people are totally uh
substitutable for one another where we
think that men and women are basically
identical and one can become the other
and vice
versa we we live in an age where we
don't even recognize National borders
and we say anybody is an American if you
only believe it in your heart and that
isn't true that just isn't true people
are different families are different
cultures are different history has a big
effect on that and conservatives ought
to prefer the particular to the
universal to the abstract to the distant
the near to the distant the tried to the
untried I'm paraphrasing the great
political philosopher Michael Oak shot
here we we ought to have an affection
for our own for our own history our own
culture our own land our own shared
experience and so I I don't like that
the MF flower Society is is embro in
this high stakes Feud but I do like that
it's making headlines and I think that
we all ought to take a little bit more
care for our own families and our own
family history and we can do that while
we smoke man flower cigars speaking of
making
babies a little bit of a hard transition
as it were there's a headline here that
I totally believe I don't usually trust
the scientists but on this issue I do
scientists warn sex toys can cause
diabetes Now if you're listening to this
show you probably
you know you're a wholesome person
you're not you probably don't do too
much of this but if you if you're
involved in this get rid of it it will
give you diabetes according to the
scientists how is that well because
microplastic
particles from numerous
sources are ingested and absorbed into
the
bloodstream this is true when you drink
a bottle of water this is true as you
just move about our environment which
has some pollution in it but apparently
it's especially true with sex choice
which are far less regulated and which
can include higher uh levels of phalates
which can affect hormone levels and in
present concentrations exceed us
consumer warnings they outline here the
four types of currently available sex
toys that are the worst offenders I'm
not going to read those out because
they're gross and I don't even want to
think about it anymore but this is the
kind of story that I totally
buy because it proves a point that I've
long thought which is one doing weird
sex stuff has negative consequences even
if you can't foresee them and
two doing weird stuff
period often has negative consequences
even if you can't foresee it very few
people would ever think well I'm
debating using a sex toy but I sure
don't want to get diabetes someday you
wouldn't even think about it you
wouldn't think that there's any
connection between those things and yet
there can
be well I really want to do this thing
or that thing but I don't want to catch
monkey pox well okay all right that's
that was an issue that a couple years
ago some New Yorkers especially were
dealing with but I I love the the rule
applied even more broadly it's such a
conservative point of view forget the
weird sex stuff for a
second conservatives tend to prefer the
tried to the
untried the familiar to the
unfamiliar in part out of prejudice
because we're not going to write a 20
page research paper on every single
question that we have in the day we're
just going to have to go on our gut
instinct otherwise you wouldn't be able
to get out of bed and when we see that
something has been done everywhere for
all of human history just about
everywhere on Earth certainly every
civilized place on Earth we tend to
believe that's a good behavior and we
ought to consider adopting it or
continuing it when we see that a certain
Behavior or conception has never been
practiced anywhere on Earth ever until
say 5 minutes ago we tend to recoil from
that a great example of this would be
marriage for all of human history
virtually everywhere on Earth marriage
has meant something and it's involved
sexual difference and
complimentarity about eight years ago a
romantic poet sitting on the Supreme
Court decided to totally invert that
idea and a lot of people said well what
could go wrong what could go wrong what
could go wrong what could go wrong by
redefining the fundamental political
institution what could go wrong by
inverting the conception of human nature
that we've had everywhere on Earth for
all of human history I don't know I I
can't I I do know I could list a hundred
different things that could go wrong but
there there actually a thousand there
are 2,000 things that could go wrong you
couldn't even predict that sex toys will
give you
diabetes surely you can't predict all of
the unforeseen consequences that come
along with
redefining reordering fundamental
aspects of our politics which is why we
ought to proceed with a great deal of
caution when we do such things if we
wish to proceed that way at all you got
to protect your political order and the
fundamental political unit is the family
when when you want to protect the family
when you want to protect just yourself
you got to check out Pac Shield right
now go to pacsh shield.com promo code
nolles Pak shield.com promo code nles
whether you are a parent frequent
traveler simply an individual seeking
enhanced personal safety you got to
check out Pac Shield Pac Shield is a
ballistic insert that fits into
backpacks messenger bags and briefcases
the insert Sears meet the National
Institute of justice and 3A standards to
stop a 44 magnum pack Shield comes in a
variety of sizes and colors so they can
be easily transferred from bag to bag
and weigh less than most textbooks and
laptops when properly packed in your bag
this remarkable insert can provide an
extra layer of protection it is
stressful to think about a situation
where you might need pack Shield but
it's worth it to be ready pack Shield
provides extra peace of mind but it's
important to know how to carry it
correctly pack Shield should never be
used for any reason other than personal
defense so pack some protection and some
peace of mind with Pac Shield check them
out for yourself at Pac shield.com promo
code nkw for 2020% off that is Pak
shield.com promo code nolles for 20% off
today my favorite comment yesterday is
from Aaron Canfield 76 who says when
Snoop actually quits weed that will be
the day that lambs have come to Lay With
Lions so true so so true that is one
that's in one of the Lesser remembered
passages about the
apocalypse and in that day Snoop Dizzle
ddoo dog will lay down his sin
spinach okay I said forget about weird
sex stuff for a second we're now going
to go back to the weird sex stuff
because I missed a very important
holiday we are heading into
Thanksgiving then we will be an advent
then we will have Christmas then we will
have new year then we will have Arbor
Day at some point but there's one
holiday more sacred than any of them
according to our political Elites that
is of course
[Music]
the speaking of leftism in government
there's a leaked NSA
document that is defining all sorts of
woke terms now this is we're not talking
about the I don't know EPA we're not
talking about the Department of
Education even we're not talking about
one of these silly government agencies
the the office of personnel management
we're talking about the NSA no such
agency this shadowy government agency
that collects all of your D and knows
everything about you and can really
punish you if they want to this group is
defining in its diversity
glossery uh White Europeans as being
responsible for settler colonialism this
this group the NSA is attacking white
fragility the the nsa's warning of
misogyny there are over 300 27 Dei terms
listed over 34 pages with words like Zer
and whiteness and pansexual this report
coming from Spencer linquist of the
daily wire and it reminds me this is
nothing new the adoption of these
left-wing terms by mainstream groups is
nothing new I happen to write a book
about it called speechless controlling
words controlling Minds great to pick up
for hello hello no one's in the office
today everyone's already on vacation a
great great to pick up for Black Friday
and for
Christmas the the left coins these crazy
terms and redefines these
ideas but that's not the end of the
story they then have to impose it on the
mainstream that's the harder Challenge
and they've succeeded at it in Chris
rufo's excellent new book uh he he
points out that Angela Davis the
Communist terrorist from the 60s and 70s
black power activist she bragged she has
bragged in recent years about how terms
that were on the radical left Fringe are
now in the mainstream terms like white
supremacy all the terms associated with
intersectionality they're in the
mainstream now they're and and because
words are not merely tools that we use
to communicate but they actually
constitute much of our Consciousness
when you can just get those terms into
the air then that that forms the lens
through which everybody conservatives
included very often view the
World okay before we move on to member
block there's one story out of New York
but illegal
aliens who you know in the words of even
a liberal Democrat mayor Eric Adams
illegal
aliens uh and the migrant crisis they've
caused could destroy New York City well
now some New Yorkers not just
politicians on the ground New Yorkers
are pushing back because illegal aliens
are getting free Thanksgiving food ahead
of the poor New Yorkers a food fight in
one neighborhood in Queens between Nitra
tenants and newly arrived migrants Fox
Ashley Rodriguez shows us how tensions
are growing with not enough food to go
around why do we have to take the butt
of everything okay this community here
is already suffering the residents
living in nich's Queensbridge houses
look forward to the mobile food pantries
that show up weekly but over the past
year they have witnessed 8,000 migrants
moving to their neighborhood and theyve
also noticed the migrants are also
starting to take their stuff they was
first online for the turkeys this
morning if they tell you to be there at
11:00 you get there like 10:30 10:45 but
they already out there the line is from
over there to over here free food
giveaways especially during the holidays
have become a source of tension between
longtime New Yorkers struggling to get
by and newly arrived migrants who are
using the system to survive a month ago
one altercation got so heated between a
resident and a migrant someone ended up
in the hospital we would never turn
anyone away for a meal but there simply
just is not enough for both Nitro
residents and the migrant shelter
residents what the left does brilliantly
here is they exploit a little kernel of
Truth to invert the truth it's like it's
the fake news which is they say well in
your charity especially on Thanksgiving
you should of course share with the
stranger and the Foreigner
yeah of course I totally agree with
that but does that mean that that in
order to fulfill that uh Act of Charity
we should take things away from our
fellow
countrymen that we should deny to the
poor here in
America the food on Thanksgiving so that
we can give it to foreigners who have
exploited our system and broken our laws
I don't that's not what that means that
would that's rather unjust
I don't find that particularly
charitable at all yeah we're going to go
into one of the worst neighborhoods in
New York and we're going to take away
food from all you guys all you poor New
Yorkers and we're going to give it to
illegal aliens who break our
laws many of whom are mobbed up with the
cartel yeah that's what we're going to
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
even if you want to give to the to the
Foreigner it's a it's a violation of
charity for your fellow men because
charity does in fact begin at home and
this is an abundant country there's a
lot to go around
but this is a part of a deeper
ideology that says not only should we
not prefer the familiar to the foreign
not only should we not prefer the near
and the Practical to the abstract and
the
universal we should actually only prefer
the abstractions we should only support
the foreigners we should totally deny
any sense of filial piety
patriotism or concern for our community
not a very good message for Thanksgiving
so that wouldn't be the message of the
pilgrims no sir nothing American about
that the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code NS canw check out for 2
months free on all annual
[Music]
plans